[Música]
y
aquí comienza el debate de france 24 mi
nombre es ángela gómez y los acompaño en
este programa para analizar desde puntos
de vista opuestos el conflicto de
cocaleros que transcurre en bolivia
desde principios de agosto el mercado
oficial es dirigido por freddy machicado
dos de adepcoca se enfrenta al gobierno
y a los cultivadores a cargo de un
mercado paralelo que dirige arnold alan
es afín al oficialista más los episodios
de violencia afectan gravemente en la
paz y los cocaleros de adepcoca dicen
que no pararán hasta que cierre el
mercado abierto en miraflores para este
análisis nos acompañan el del lado
opositor ya favor de los cocaleros de
coca luisana ya la diputada nacional de
bolivia y también hay que atenderle de
burrell directora de la red andina de
información en favor del oficialismo
ambas gracias por estar con nosotros y a
nuestros televidentes que también les
recuerdo que hacen parte de esta
conversación dejen sus preguntas y sus
comentarios en nuestras redes sociales
estamos en twitter instagram y facebook
donde no se encuentran con arrobo
france24 guión bajo
y angel ago efe 24 mi cuenta personal la
etiqueta de es el numeral el debate efe
24 en youtube pueden seguir nuestra
señal en streaming y también saludamos a
quienes nos escuchan en nuestro podcast
no olviden que todos los contenidos de
este programa están disponibles en app
el podcast spotify deezer y también en
tuning
los enfrentamientos entre las dos
facciones se tienen el foco en el
funcionamiento de un punto de venta
distinto al tradicional mercado de villa
fátima donde se comercializa la coca
legal de los yungas un mercado que opera
desde hace casi medio siglo
vamos así a comenzar quisiera arrancar
con luisa luisa los enfrentamientos
entre los cocaleros tienen su origen en
política porque el mercado liderado por
la oposición no se mantiene en las
calles
muy buenas tardes
angela buenas tardes a catering un
saludo cordial para todos los que nos
están acompañando otra vez detrás 24 en
primera instancia hay que dejar con
total claridad que le toca que es el
mercado legal establecido en los yungas
no viene hace ser un ente
politizado o un ente político no
pertenece a ninguna tienda política y
más al contrario en su momento algunos
dirigentes de adepcoca se han visto más
bien cerca del movimiento al socialismo
acá hay que aclarar que hacer coca en el
mercado legal establecido por normativa
y dentro de lo que viene hacer
los yungas establecido en el
departamento de la paz en este entendido
la normativa establece justamente que
tanto a de coca como el mercado de
sacaba son los únicos dos mercados
autorizados por ley para poder
comercializar evidentemente la hoja de
coca
vemos lamentablemente en contrapartida
si ha existido una politización por
parte del oficialismo que evidentemente
habría favorecido a otros los
productores de un mercado paralelo que
en días pasados han sido descubiertos
portando dinamita que habrían sido
descubiertos con bombas molotov que
habrían sido descubiertos también
inclusive con ametralladoras adentro de
este mercado ilegal pero no solamente
eso angela sino que también tendrían
bolsas con hojas de coca picada que
evidentemente van destinadas a un
mercado ilegal y eso no lo dice luis
sanz ayer eso está aquí registrado en
fotografías que han sido encontradas
hacia adentro del propio mercado ilegal
y evidentemente pues la hoja picada no
es para pinchar no es para hacer un bolo
la hoja picada se utiliza para
destinarla al mercado ilegal de la
producción de cocaína en este entendido
nosotros vamos a rechazar enfáticamente
desde cualquier punto de vista qué
pretenden camuflar esta coca ilegal en
un mercado legal como lo viene a ser el
día de coca muy bien me di que tiene
ledebur ahora voy con usted misma
pregunta enfrentamientos entre los
cocaleros tienen su origen en un corte
político y porque la oposición se
mantiene en las calles
bueno yo creo que no hay qué
caracterizarlo como enfrentamientos lo
que tenemos es un grupo que está ahorita
posicionado del mercado de adepcoca un
grupo que no ha sido legítimamente
elegido un grupo que desde hace varios
años no transparentan las cuentas no
permite una auditoría externa para
demostrar porque a los ingresos y en la
cantidad del dinero que se mueve a
través del mercado y del uso de coca
legal son montos elevadísimo no entonces
lo que tenemos son dos sectores el grupo
de matica lo que se ha posicionado en el
mercado envía fátima que no lo sueltan
que ha habido repetidamente
problemas de que no hayan permitido los
otros productores de coca o productores
de coca que exigen nuevas elecciones y
han habido
elecciones dos veces
a uno que cuando fue electa elena flores
antes de lo que resultó ser un duro
golpe de estado un golpe de estado
antiguo calero hubo más masaje de
cocaleros del trópico de cochabamba un
gobierno interino alto nombrado apoyado
por el partido de la diputada en ayer no
y que que ha sido una perpetuación de un
grupo
manejando el mercado que no tiene el
derecho legal de hacerlo y hay un fallo
legal que respalde eso él era flores fue
encarcelada más que un año no y el uso
de dinamita claramente por la parte de
este grupo uno de los señores que estaba
apoyando al grupo voló la mano no por el
mal manejo de dinamita es muy extraño en
un conflicto con calero y yo trabajo con
productores de coca desde hace 25 años
que utilizan dinamita
ha habido enfrentamientos han habido
lanzamiento de dinamita y lo que ha
habido el jueves pasado es un ataque de
parte del grupo de mágica al mercado al
alternativo donde han quemado donde han
saqueado donde han clasificado donde han
desnudado a las personas han habido
heridos policía seriamente heridas hay
lo de la coca molida y yo voy a la coca
morir se puede utilizar para la
producción de la cocaína pero
generalmente uno no hace el esfuerzo de
llevarlo al mercado oficial
como para hacerlo eso se pierde en la
senda y se vuelve a hacer con la cocaína
en otro lado entonces es muy importante
entender la la no legitimidad del grupo
de machicao y jim y yo destacaría que el
gobierno del más en ese entonces el
anterior gobierno de marc fue gobernado
por un productor de coca este cabinet es
el más es muy distinto y no hay una
visión o no hay al conocimiento de coca
y no ha habido privilegios para el grupo
debía carmen más bien lo que vemos
constantemente es que el grupo de villa
fátima y el grupo de mágica o
consistentemente rechazan cualquier
diálogo
y tiene que haber la voluntad de
solucionar el conflicto tiene que haber
la voluntad tal vez de modificar la ley
90 ustedes que dice que debe haber un
mercado en la paz y el mercado de
adepcoca
pero falta legalmente determinar cuál es
el área de coca legítimo y según el
último fallo fue el grupo de albaneses y
no el grupo de machicao viene luisa
sobre ese tema usted que tiene que decir
porque ustedes se cobijan en que la ley
los protege y en que precisamente hay
hay un reconocimiento en el departamento
de la paz del mercado de la asociación
departamental de productores de coca y
en el mercado del departamento de
cochabamba el mercado de sacaba y esto
está en el artículo 24 numerales 2
en primera instancia aquí con todo
respeto le vamos a pedir a la señora que
no trate de incluir un falso golpe de
estado que nunca existió en esta
temática nada tiene que ver una cosa con
la otra
hasta el momento sin hablar de un falso
golpe de estado su justicia corrupta y
manejada por el partido del gobierno
hasta ahora ha logrado evitar un fallo
que cataloga como golpe de estado porque
no tienen las pruebas porque todo lo que
dice son mentiras entonces por favor le
pido a la otra panelista que no se
desvíe del tema y nos enfoquemos en este
hecho que evidentemente está haciendo
nuevamente ha socavado por el gobierno
al más nosotros vamos a hablar en
relación a las propias autoridades del
gobierno luís arce que son el gobierno
del movimiento al socialismo
presidido por el señor evo morales-
cocalero y que es dirigente sindical de
las seis federaciones del trópico de
cochabamba hace 17 años
aquí el señor eduardo el castillo
tampoco lo digo yo lo dice la prensa ha
salido del abierta y públicamente a
manifestar lo dice del castillo lo que
determine la asamblea de adecco que será
acatado por las instancias
gubernamentales toda vez de que ha de
coca es una instancia privada al ser
privada no tendría por qué haber
discusión por parte del gobierno pero
más bien es lo primero que hacen y aquí
ha quedado totalmente ratificado cuando
la señora catherine manifiesta
y su postura en torno a las elecciones
las elecciones se han suscitado y
evidentemente quien ahora pone como
presidente el señor machicado quien
evidentemente también ahora está
liderizando que se respete el mercado
legal establecido y consagra una
normativa y que con claridad está
establecido en la norma ahora la
intransigencia en el manejo de este
conflicto depende enteramente del
gobierno porque ha de cocca una
instancia privada pero lo que no es
privado es la regulación de la venta la
regulación del traslado de la hoja de
coca porque todo es una competencia de
manera directa del gobierno central el
ministerio de desarrollo rural y tierra
es el encargado justamente de que pueda
llevarse este proceso con total
transparencia pero ahora en lugar de
brindar garantías y certezas en torno a
credibilidad simplemente dos mercados
legales hoy por hoy lo que buscan es
encubrir y camuflar la hoja de coca
ilegal dentro de este mercado legal que
viene acera de época entonces bajo
ningún punto de vista podemos admitir
que hoy por hoy lo que estén haciendo
desde el gobierno es tratar de camuflar
una vez más estas irregularidades que
van después vinculadas a la droga
tenemos a la fecha 13 radares adquiridos
durante la sesión 2015 dentro del
gobierno de evo morales que eran
adquiridos justamente para la lucha
contra el narcotráfico pero resulta
acerca viendo transcurridos siete años
hasta la fecha no funcionan tenemos
informes de organismos internacionales
donde se establece que el 94 por ciento
de la hoja de coca producida por ejemplo
en el chapare va destinada también al
mercado ilegal entonces estamos hablando
de que hoy tristemente el narcotráfico
se estaría campeando en bolivia y esto
estaría siendo encubierto desde las
fuera del gobierno central no utilizar
set o radares adquiridos con recursos lo
boliviano bueno esa es una acusación muy
grave luisa pero vamos a darle espacio
también a que estén para que pueda
participar y para que nos pueda dar su
punto de vista que tiene usted cree que
los esfuerzos del gobierno han sido
insuficientes para frenar la violencia y
que decir pues de esta denuncia de un
mercado ilegal
bueno
recalco como trabajo en el tema de lucha
contra el narcotráfico y coca nunca
llega coca que es a un mercado que está
destinado a un mercado ilegal la esa
coca se va desviando se va produciendo
una pasta básica que es llevada a través
del beni a través del centro de lavado
de dinero de santa cruz nunca llegó un
mercado lo que los bolivianos necesitan
son mercados legales y regulados y eso
existe en el mercado debía carmen yo
creo que el punto del golpe que es algo
que ha sido claramente sostenido por la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos y el grupo de expertos de la del
pedido de las fuerzas armadas de la
renuncia de morales tanto como el auto
nombramiento de una presidenta que hay
en violación del reglamento del estado
dice algo muy bien porque lo que estamos
viendo es el uso de dinamita
la quema de instalaciones son re
aplicaciones de los comportamientos que
vimos durante el golpe de 2019 y 2020 y
que se están repitiendo y no son cosas
que caben dentro de un estado de derecho
entonces los que han llamado el mercado
de vía que carmen merecen consecuencias
legales los que han golpeado los que han
formulado los que han asaltado por
ejemplo radio la xunta
anteanoche merecen consecuencias legales
y la solución de este conflicto es una
solución que tiene que ser
administrativa o de la modificación de
la ley o en base de la negociación de
ambas partes pero eso quiere decir que
la parte de temática tiene que sentarse
y negociar y hasta este momento a través
de varios intentos
han querido hacer esto abre el gobierno
ver más en este momento
no está apoyando el grupo de la hallan
es no ha tomado una posición clara pero
sí ha protegido la población en la zona
debía caer medida sólo de villa fátima
porque imagínense que hay cargas de
dinamita
gases lacrimógenas al conflicto
permanente donde los niños pues no
pueden ir a la escuela y donde los
vecinos no pueden vivir en paz entonces
esas acusaciones de narcotráfico eso me
parece que ese es el mismo discurso de
siempre cuando sabemos muy bien que no
es el productor de coca que rinde
ganancias altas son los que producen
pasta básica los que refieren cocaína lo
que transportan ese cocaína y estos son
fuera generalmente de los
lugares de producción de la hoja de coca
filial y es muy importante dividir las
dos cosas bueno está claro que los años
no se ve que han sucedido en la paz en
miraflores en las zonas residenciales
han sido muy difíciles y esto es lo que
está capoteando en este momento la
fuerza pública pero en estos
enfrentamientos hay heridos y además se
pues se dice del coma que no va a
detener sus manifestaciones pasando un
poco de tema a favor o en contra evo
morales es un gran personaje del país y
aquí les quiero preguntar a las dos cuál
es la influencia de morales en este
conflicto su presencia en las protestas
porque ha participado en varias prepara
un posible regreso al poder en un año y
medio pensaría alguno de ustedes 12 de
comienzo con el catering
bueno yo no se sabe de hasta 2025 es una
eternidad no política en bolivia tiene
el derecho legal ero evo morales de
candidatearse pero eso no está definido
no hay
ha expresado una opinión y no ha
participado en la paz en en
manifestaciones sobre este tema ha
habilitado a los yungas y al en alguna
zona estos conflictos internos que son
internos entre años siempre ha sido un
dolor de cabeza para el gobierno de
armas no y youtube es por ejemplo otro
tipo de coche bajo ya que es una zona
mucho más unificada entonces no estamos
en un momento donde el gobierno de luis
arse obedece a evo morales tienen una
autonomía y tienen un gabinete mucho
menos vinculado con los movimientos
sociales y con ministros de clase
media-alta
y no responde a los dictámenes de
morales morales hace declaraciones
constantemente pero se ha ido enfocando
en otros
temas y no específicamente en este tema
de los yungas que no es algo mi
estimulado
y apoyado ni perpetuado por moral
luisa da su opinión
bueno primero hay que desmentir porno
aquí cuando hablan de que no existe
apoyo del gobierno acá tenemos nosotros
documentos y noticias del castillo
retira públicamente su apoyo a la cne y
recibe críticas del oficialismo luego de
haber apoyado públicamente al señor alan
otra noticia para apoyar públicamente a
la cne del castillo ahora dice que no
responderá a ninguna diligencia estamos
hablando de que ha habido discusión por
parte directa del ministro de gobierno
el ministro de gobierno que el llamado a
guardar el orden dentro del estado
estaba en miku yéndose dentro de unas
elecciones de una asociación interna de
producción y comercialización de hoja de
coca entonces que no vengan a decirnos
de que no existió ningún tipo de vínculo
con el gobierno cuando el castillo
públicamente apoyaba al señor alan quien
es el que hoy por hoy está promoviendo
al mercado ilegal de
evidentemente los yungas
ahora por el otro lado hemos visto una
fuerte
crisis y una implosión hacia dentro del
movimiento al socialismo que esto se
debe a pugnar político partidaria por un
lado se tiene al señor evo morales y por
el otro lado se tiene al señor luis arse
evo morales que está enfermo de poder y
que no entendió nunca lo que era el
estado de derecho ni la democracia en el
país porque vulnera la constitución
política del estado porque vulnera los
resultados de un referéndum el 21 de
febrero y por que vulneró y cometió un
gigantesco fraude electoral en las
elecciones del 2019 entonces ahora hoy
por hoy en la búsqueda enferma
nuevamente del poder está inclusive
lanzando acusaciones frontales en contra
de chino y funge como presidente del
estado que tiene muchísimo hecho de
corrupción que nosotros hemos sido
duramente crítico con este gobierno lo
hemos sido y lo vamos a seguir siendo y
vamos a seguir cristalizando pero entre
el señor arce y el señor evo morales-
excitan pugnas políticos partidarias que
prioricen los intereses del más y no así
la construcción y la mejora y las
soluciones para el país eso no lo vamos
a permitir bajo ningún punto de vista
porque acá se tiene que poner primero
la solución a las necesidades de los
problemas de la gente porque mientras
los ciudadanos de a pie están buscando
cómo llegar a fin de mes estos
personajes se andan peleando por
ministerio lo han dicho abierta y
públicamente se andan peleando por ver
quién tiene más cobertura en los medios
de comunicación inclusive en días
pasados el propio ex presidente o
morales le ha reclamado al presidente
luís arce que el canal estatal le corta
sus discursos de qué estamos hablando
mientras hay gente que no puede ser
atendida para atención contra el cáncer
mientras hay personas que
lamentablemente no tienen trabajo
mientras hay personas que están
padeciendo por llevar adelante el
sustento a sus hogares tristemente
tenemos hasta unas y esta pelea hacia
dentro del movimiento al socialismo que
nada benefician a la población boliviana
que nosotros hacemos un llamado a la
reflexión a todos estos personajes del
más para que produce más interrumpirlo
en cuentas con ranieri varias no puede
pasarse de tres minutos porque quisiera
darles a las dos la misma y al mismo
tiempo para hablar y aquí mi siguiente
pregunta queda trino el gobierno dice
que la oposición de derecha está armando
o intentando hermano un golpe de estado
contra luís arce en el poder desde
noviembre de 2020 eso es lo que se dice
desde el oficialismo
usted cómo lo ve
bueno como yo le dije antes el golpe las
actividades de quemas de mercado de
ataques de usos de grupos paraestatales
que también han sido presentes en este
conflicto de
temática o son elementos problemáticos
preocupantes que hacen eco al golpe de
y hacen eco a los anteriores golpes de
estado entonces la pregunta es por qué
se hace en mi escuela derecha que ha
tenido un discurso anti indígena anti
campesino que nunca han tenido un
respaldo campesino en este conflicto
porque participan activamente porque los
abogados del grupo paraestatal a la
unión juvenil cruceñista más la
resistencia juvenil coche la masia line
año porque está participando en estas
marchas cuando no entienden el tema de
coca cuando en el momento del golpe han
quemado y
sacado del palacio los símbolos de
pueblos indígenas no podemos tener estas
actitudes no de violencia de quema de
ataque y lo que yo veo es que en ese
momento una parte del problema de por
qué persiste que se revive eso es que
existe impunidad por muchos de los
actores claves y en el golpe del estado
actores políticos tanto como miembros de
las fuerzas de seguridad y otros
elementos claves y tampoco existe
justicia para las
centenares de torturados para las
víctimas de las dos masacres que se
llevaron a cabo al principio del golpe
de estado entonces no de la posibilidad
de que se sanen la sociedad boliviana
porque no hay consecuencias legales por
los actos indebidos entonces estamos
viendo el rebote de brotes de violencia
y actores que están con muchas ganas de
agitar la situación y no podemos volver
a eso porque el golpe rompió el periodo
más largo de democracia en la historia
de bolivia y ahora este tiene que
permanecer en la democracia bolivia y el
sistema de justicia tiene que tratar los
casos pendientes
louis a usted que considera de esta
acusación de que la oposición de derecha
está intentando efectuar un golpe de
estado contra luis arse
causa gracia puedan vela porque
justamente ahora dentro de esta pugna
partidaria flagrantemente y abiertamente
de manera extemporánea a una campaña
electoral el señor evo morales y el
señor arse se acusan de manera directa
acá tenemos también nuevamente más
noticia plan negro evo envite al
ejecutivo y se indica al vicepresidente
y a otras 15 personas por el otro lado
coincide con el plan negro aunque fue
descartado desde el gabinete
evidentemente el único que parece ser
que le quiere generar un golpe de estado
al presidente darse del señor evo
morales el señor evo morales se
encuentra en una franca guerra repito
extemporánea a una campaña electoral
contra el presidente luis arse acá lo
único que están buscando una
inestabilidad hacia adentro del gobierno
vienen a hacer el señor evo morales y su
ex ministro que en días pasados
justamente también han sido indicado por
el actual ministro de gobierno eduardo
del castillo el juego los ha tildado de
ser un cáncer para el movimiento al
socialismo eso tampoco lo hice la
diputada luisan ayer lo dice el propio
funcionario designado por el presidente
luis arce entonces acá repito no se
puede priorizar una pugna político
partidaria antes que priorizar el
resolver las necesidades que tenemos los
bolivianos entonces repito que debemos
hacer un llamado a la reflexión a las
autoridades que hoy están fungiendo el
poder porque la gente necesita
reactivación económica la gente necesita
trabajo y la gente necesita una correcta
atención de salud y una buena educación
para nuestros niños y para nuestros
jóvenes
luisa y no le parece a usted que sería
viable las soluciones de que este
mercado paralelo que ha sido creado se
mantenga en funcionamiento finalmente
pues también son cocaleros los que están
trabajando allí ahora la copa exige la
promulgación de un decreto supremo que
reconozca que la coca es el único
mercado legal de la zona de los yungas y
el que funciona en villa fátima al norte
en la ciudad de la paz
quienes deben resolver este conflicto
ahora son justamente los cocaleros son
los cocaleros que hoy se encuentran en
esta disputa son los cocaleros que hoy
por hoy lamentablemente están siendo
vulnerados en su derecho al haberse
encontrado en este mercado ilegal
jeringas para ser lanzadas a los
manifestantes que han encontrado
dinamita para ser lanzadas también hacia
los mismos que han encontrado repito
bombas molotov e inclusive un
ametralladora para ser utilizada hacia
los manifestantes entonces bajo ningún
punto de vista puede haber en mi función
por parte de nosotros esto tiene que ser
resuelto con las instancias respectivas
que justamente viene a ser el ministerio
de
desarrollo rural y tierra y también los
implicados en este conflicto nosotros
esperamos que esto pueda resolverse a la
brevedad posible y esperamos que
justamente los cocaleros que están en el
mercado legal puedan ser respetados en
sus derechos
y para ustedes cuál es la solución es
posible la coexistencia de dos el día
que ha estado por casi medio siglo en
villa fátima y el que ha sido instalado
en miraflores además este conflicto no
viene desde principios de agosto esto es
un tema de años que sube y baja con la
marea
bueno es un tema de años eso es un tema
donde hay cual como 43.000 socios en un
mercado es muy interesante que muchos 12
surgió de copec a el organización
sindical
cocalera este adecco que muchos de los
fundadores de adepcoca los que han
construido el mercado y rechazan el
liderazgo de machicao entonces no es una
cosa blanco y negro pero no es una cosa
que se resuelve con dinamita y destacó
que los heridos excepto el señor que
perdió su mano por mal manejo de
dinamitas los heridos son por parte del
grupo de allá me para mí la solución es
un diálogo
pragmático la inspección y la revisión
posible de la ley 906 porque hay un ver
solo mercado de adepcoca pero no dice
cuál es legal y dónde está pero también
en el trópico de cochabamba hay un
mercado
y vendría bien poner un mercado en dos
mercados también en el trópico de
cochabamba hacia la ciudad de santa cruz
de donde es luisa porque el mayor
consumo consumo de coca legal ahora está
en el departamento de santa cruz no y es
es mucho mejor tener mercados legales
regulados por el estado que un descuido
o coca que no está controlado es muy
importante y por ejemplo para que los
que que estén en otros países por
ejemplo el precio legal de la coca es
como siete meses más alto que el precio
en colombia y es un ingreso ilícito
controlado digno para esas familias
cocaleras y tenemos que mantener esa
legalidad
y si es ampliar la ley dar una
solución salomónica tener dos mercados
en ambas zonas eso es algo que es
legislativamente posible tiene que haber
la apertura del grupo de mágica de ver
soluciones para terminar el conflicto y
no ver maneras de agudizar la
permanentemente
bien y ya para ir cerrando luisa usted
no ve que puede haber voluntad política
para hacer una modificación desde la ley
entendiendo que este es un conflicto que
ya lleva años y que en algún momento hay
que sentarse a dialogar
hay que hacer claro en lo siguiente
angela si hubiera existido la voluntad
política por parte del gobierno ya se
hubiese realizado la modificación
respectiva el movimiento el socialismo
tiene la mayoría dentro del congreso y
al tener la mayoría ellos deciden
siempre con su rodillo parlamentario que
normativa se aprueban y te normativa se
quedan a dormir vamos a decir
vulgarmente en las comisiones porque
lamentablemente los más de 150 proyectos
de ley que se han presentado desde la
oposición no han llegado al pleno de la
cámara de diputado y tampoco de la
cámara de senadores entonces alcalde
ante la responsabilidad recae en el
partido de gobierno que hoy por hoy
tiene la mayoría parlamentaria que es la
que puede aprobar o no la normativa y
justamente puede
ahora la voluntad política se verá por
parte de ellos pero vemos de que
lamentablemente año tras año hace
bastante tiempo atrás ya no han logrado
resolver este conflicto ni inclusive
cuando tenían los dos tercios hacia
adentro de la asamblea legislativa
porque lo último que les importa es
legalizar siempre buscan la informalidad
esto lo vemos reflejado no solamente con
la coca lo vemos con la lucha contra el
narcotráfico dos veces se han incautado
en días pasados avioneta que cayó con
droga en paraguay fue incautada en
bolivia y piloto trabaja es boa
imagínense angela una avioneta que había
sido incautada para a favor del estado
boliviano ahora resulta ser que se
encontraban trasladando droga hacia el
paraguay y entonces estamos hablando que
el último interés que existe es el que
se luche contra el narcotráfico y una
arista evidentemente de la lucha contra
el narcotráfico viene a ser el tema de
la producción de la hoja de coca ilegal
entonces esto depende enteramente de la
voluntad política que demuestre el
movimiento al socialismo muy bien me
quedan pocos minutos sus conclusiones
ella para el cierre de este debate
bueno yo diría que es una situación
completa tal vez la luisa que la bancada
de cc pudieran proponer este cambio de
la ley de coca no entonces si hay un
problema de una división en el máster yo
les recuerdo que son la segunda bancada
más grande en en el congreso y que
existe la posibilidad desde su bajada
también tomar iniciativas legislativas
que podría conducir a una solución
pacífica a este
a este conflicto también remarcar que la
hoja de coca es más pegada
regulado y más controlado en el estado
plurinacional de bolivia que en
cualquier otro país está mucho mejor que
en el perú y en colombia y destacar por
ejemplo que en bolivia hay
aproximadamente 30 mil hectáreas no
comparado con más de 100 mil hectáreas
en colombiano entonces tomar en cuenta
que es posible lograr y que es imposible
lograr y notar que el narcotráfico
existe existe en todos los países pero
no es una cuestión de la noche a la
mañana solucionarlo y cuando los
gobiernos por ejemplo un pariente de
louis estaba en gobierno en el pasado y
tampoco han podido frenar el
narcotráfico con los grandes ganancias
que se tienen
muy bien muchísimas gracias eran luis
anaya a favor de los cocaleros de
adepcoca diputada nacional de bolivia y
que tiene el devour directora de la red
andina de información va a ser gracias
por este enriquecedor momento ya
nuestros televidentes siguen en france
[Música]